let's say we are operating in three
dimensions and i have a function rho
which is a function of x y or z and it
gives us the mass density at any point
in three dimensions of some fluid some
particular fluid maybe it's a gas or
fluid water who knows what it is some
type of substance it gives us the mass
density at any point in three dimensions
and let's say we have another
function this is a scalar function it
just gives us a number for any point in
3d and then let's say we have another
function v which is a vector function it
gives us a vector for any point in three
dimensions and this right over here
tells us the velocity of that same
the velocity of that same fluid or gas
or whatever we're talking about now
let's imagine another function and this
might all look a little bit familiar
because we did we went through a very
similar exercise in two dimensions when
we talked about line integrals now we're
just extending it to three dimensions
let's say we have a function f
let's say we have a function f and it is
equal to the product
the product of rho and v so for any
point in x y z this will give us a
vector and then we'll multiply times
this scalar right over here for that
same point in three dimensions so it's
equal to
rho
times v
times
times v let me use that same color that
i used for v before
rho
rho times
times v and there's a couple of ways you
could conceptualize this you could view
this as it obviously maintains the
direction of the velocity but now it's
magnitude one way to think about it is
kind of the momentum density if that
doesn't make too much sense you don't
have to worry too much about it
hopefully as we use these two functions
and we talk think a little bit more
about them relative to a surface it'll
make a little bit more conceptual sense
now what i want to do is think about
what it means what it means given this
function f to evaluate the surface
integral
over some surface so we're going to
value it over some surface we're going
to evaluate
f
we're going to evaluate f dot
n
where n is the unit normal vector at
every at each point on that surface
d
s d capital s d surface so let's think
about what this is saying
so first let me draw my axes
so i have my z axis
z axis this could be my
let's make that let's make that my
x-axis and let's say that this right
over here is my
y-axis and let's say my surface i'll use
that same color my surface looks
something like that
so that is my surface
that is the surface in question that is
s now let's think about the units and
hopefully that will give us conceptual
understanding of what this thing right
over here is measuring it's completely
analogous to what we did in the
two-dimensional case with line integrals
so we have a ds a ds is a little chunk
of area of that surface so that is ds so
this is going to be area and if we want
to prick this is if we want to pick
particular units this could be
square this could be square meters and i
think when you do particular units it
starts to make a little bit more
concrete sense now the normal vector at
that ds the normal vector is going to
point right out of it it's literally
normal to that plane
it's literally normal to that plane it
has a magnitude one so that is our unit
normal vector and f is defined
throughout this three-dimensional space
you give me any x y z i'll know its mass
density i'll know its velocity and i'll
get some f i'll get some f at any point
at any point in three dimensional space
including on this surface including
right over here so right over here f
might look
f might look something like this so that
is f right at that point
right at that point so what does all
this mean well when you take the dot
product of two vectors it's essentially
saying how much do they go together and
since n is a unit vector since it has a
magnitude one it's this is essentially
saying what is what is the magnitude of
the component of f that's going in the
direction of n or the what it or what is
the magnitude of the component of f that
is normal to the surface or how much of
f is normal to the surface so the
component of f that is normal to the
surface might look something like
might look something
like
that
it might look something like that and
this right over here will essentially
just give the magnitude of that and it's
just going to it's just going to keep
the units of f and right over here just
specifies the direction it has no units
associated with it it's dimensionless f
units are going to be units of mass
density so it could be
it's going to be let's say it could be
kilogram
per
meter cubed that's well that's actually
just the row part so it's mass density
times velocity times
meters per second let me write in those
colors so we have clear what's happening
here so the units of f are going to be
the units of rho which are going to be
kilogram
per cubic meter that's mass density
times the units of v which is meters per
second
meters per second and we're going to
multiply that times meters squared so
what you have is you have a meter and
then a meter squared in the numerator
that's meters cubed in the numerator and
meters cubed in the denominator that
that that cancels out and so the units
that we get for this the units that we
get for this are kilogram
per second and so the way to
conceptualize it given how we've defined
f when we say what we say f represents
the way to conceptualize this this is
saying how much mass how much mass given
this mass energy this velocity is going
directly out of this little ds this
little infinitesimally chunk of surface
in a given amount of time and then if we
add up all the ds's and this is what
essentially that surface integral is
we're essentially saying how much mass
in kilograms per second that's what we
picked how much mass is traveling across
this surface at any given moment in time
and this is really the same idea we do
with the line integrals this is
essentially the flux through a
two-dimensional surface
so this is
the flux through a 2d surface
through
through a 2d
through a 2d surface and this isn't like
some crazy
abstract thing i mean you could imagine
you know you could imagine something
like water vapor in your bathroom
water vapor in your bathroom and i like
to imagine that because that's actually
visible especially when sunlight is
shining through it and we've all seen
water vapor through a water vapor in our
bathroom when there you have a ray of
sunlight and you can see how the
particles how the particles are
traveling and you see they have a
certain density at different points and
so you can imagine you can imagine you
care about the surface
the surface of your maybe you have a
window maybe you have a window in the
bathroom
so you have a window and so if you were
if the surface was the window and the
window and let's say the window is open
so it's kind of a there's nothing
physical there it's just kind of a
rectangular surface that things can pass
freely through
if an f was essentially the mass density
of the water vapor times the velocity of
the water vapor then this thing right
over here will essentially tell you the
mass of water vapor that is traveling
through that window at any given moment
of time another way to think about it is
imagine a imagine a river and i'm going
to conceptualize this river as kind of
just a section of the river and i'm
conceptualizing it this is kind of a
river obviously this would be the
surface that we normally see but
obviously it has some depth it's three
dimensional in nature and so
we would know the density maybe it's
constant you you know the density and
you know the velocity at any point
that's what f gives us so that tells us
you as we said we could view that as the
momentum density at any given point in
time and maybe our surface is some type
of a net
our surface is some type of a net and
that doesn't even have to be rectangular
it could be some weird shaped net but
i'll do it rectangular just because it's
easy to draw it's some type of net that
in no way impedes the flow of the fluid
then once again when you evaluate this
integral will tell you the mass of fluid
that is flowing through that net at any
given moment of time so hopefully this
makes a little bit of conceptual sense
now in the next few videos we'll
actually think about how to con how to
calculate this and how we can actually
represent it in different ways